hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the amnesia
custom story obscurity now I am playing
this one right now I was gonna hold off
on this but you have been requesting it
saying it's one of the best and needs to
custom stories out there and from what I
can tell you guys are probably writing
them starting it now because I'm gonna
be out of town from Wednesday to Friday
so I'm recording a batch of episodes so
you can get a powerpack combo of Dead
Space 3 and amnesia obscurity let's get
it going
by electric red welcome to Crescent
Village Crescent Crescent god I screwed
up this early does not bode well for me
[Music]
here we go
all right seem to be waking no he starts
with me waking up in the middle of the
woods
okay I'm playing there was said that
there was gonna be I know I'm dreaming
but it always feels strangely real I'm
disoriented and confused my head hurts
except that there was gonna be good
voice acting in can already tell that
it's of much higher quality from
previous amnesia game sinaia play as I
stumble through the foliage feelings of
familiarity rush back to me it's been
here before I've been here before
well if you're talking about other
amnesia got some stories and yes I've
done however something is wrong I not
alone are you alone
oh hello what was that something is
stalking me lurking in the shadows
no thank you I'd rather not if it's all
the same I'd rather just go home in the
distance I see a house my house usually
I'm not able to reach the front door
however tonight was different
all right so what is stalking me exactly
lurking in the darkness I don't know but
I'm sure that I'll find out very soon
hey I grab the doorknob and twist it
locked
yes that's my house where did I leave
the key I do not have it on me ha as my
vision fades I hear the whisper come to
present village
well if you insist
okay well that was happy fun times great
way that start the game I thought I was
in a dream how can my vision fade in
mind electric red presents
[Music]
obscurity
Crescent village disappearances continue
the recent string of disappearances in
the small mining community of Crescent
village have continued this week with at
least four missing persons reported
locals suggest that the mines are to
blame and that the dangerous conditions
caused many people be either get lost or
caved in on haha Simon that's the
gentleman from cry of fear interesting
body found in Crescent village question
left unanswered
just yesterday afternoon a body turned
up in the forest surrounding Crescent
village police have yet to identify the
victim but it seems to be a child the
body was found mangled and almost
unrecognizable and there's no clear
cause of death analysts suggested as
must must have been the work of a large
animal
well if this game has a lot a custom
soundtrack in a custom voice acting
custom monsters it should prove to be
very good more disappearances aggressive
villain please halt the investigation
following the continuation of
disappearance in Crescent village
including a police officer police have
officially ceased the investigation
until further notice due to the lack of
leads or evidence they come to the
conclusion that the conditions in
Crescent village is simply not
inhabitable they suspect the mines are
at fault and that they are simply too
dangerous to be in operation officials
have now shut down the mines and urged
Kirstin villagers inhabitants to move
out unfortunately most of them have
nowhere to go and choose to remain in
their homes
police have abandoned the case and do
not plan on returning to the village
boom that was almost intelligible and I
spit only on half of my screen I am in a
carriage haunting me in my dreams yes it
was a small but peacefulness of town I
grew up there with my parents and my
sister I don't remember much one day my
sister died that was sent away to London
I live with my aunt uncle since then
I've never had any contact with my
family I wrote letters at first they
never responded after numerous attempts
to hear from my parents again I gave her
I thought they had forgotten about me
eventually the memories of my childhood
slipped away I became a successful
lawyer working in a small law firm I
never looked back but now my past is
haunting me these nightmares I'm having
are remnants of my childhood that's why
I'm travelling to Crescent village
something you have in there that I don't
remember did I need to confront it yeah
that's a bad idea what's that something
feels wrong about it yeah all my
instincts are telling me to stay away
from there she trusts them but
no I must rid myself of these awful life
or give you give yourself okay buddy
if you need it Who am I to stop you I
guess I could quit the game but I'm not
a pansy I will not quit the game I never
quit games right right guys okay all
right so we arrived at crescent village
at night that's fantastic
Crescent village ahead where's my
carriage carriage carriage where'd you
go what's over here I can't go that way
seems to be blocked all right so we
going into Crescent village where the
land of nightmares I'm wondering if it
has any parallels to Silent Hill you
know what I'm talking about I mean I
haven't played the Silent Hill games but
The Legend of Silent Hill is infamous
all right then I'll keep moving and not
talking you know I'm actually surprised
because a lot of these custom stories
that have a bunch of new content with
new monsters and all that they don't
have they're not full conversion mods
which I'm surprising I thought you could
only do it through full conversion mods
but I suppose I was wrong hello yeah
that's blood happened and why does the
village just seem so empty
it might have something to do with that
flawed hope I'm pretty much stranded
here well what happened to your carriage
ride buddy
successful lawyer could have hired some
protection yeah this looks good now
that's a nice fountain to have in the
middle of a town very ornamental that
baby face just creeps me the hell out
all right so this one looks properly lit
let's look here it's locked and requires
a key this reminds me of the beginning
of the things in the night I don't need
to visit the graveyard right now good do
not enter okay are they I guess I'll go
to the big building over there the big
one
seems like the only way hang on what's
over here secrets whose secrets is a
broken window on the second floor the
end I need to find a way to reach it
well a ladder would be good here's a
part of a ladder ladder piece one of
three hey not bad some interesting am
beyond excited when missing a body was
found twisted and ripped open by the
river bed this morning everyone else
thinks it must have been some kind of
animal that did it but I know what
really happened
what door seems to be barricaded shut
from the inside maybe there's another
way in ah Peppadew to do gimme gimme
gimme gimme gimme
there we go not a piece two of three the
hatch appears rusted shut I could open
it if I had some kind of leverage like a
crowbar that's just crazy enough to get
us all killed anybody I didn't I didn't
spot another ladder piece on the way in
here but there must be another one
nearby anything no alright then I
suppose not where the hell would the
last ladder piece be
I should probably turn off those hints
out probably a good idea hard as I had a
feeling you'd be down here anybody I can
go in here surprisingly till you see
elevator obtain all three fuel rods and
place them in the proper positions
when all units are in place and the door
is closed
pull the lever please follow the
appropriate safety precautions at all
times if the elevator gets stuck in the
shaft call for help and remain calm only
authorized personnel are permitted to
you see elevator okay I have no fuel rod
so let me just slam this Sun occur down
didn't work
a big surprise there all right let's
combine this combination does not work
your combination doesn't work
well you ain't you you you're okay I
guess I gotta assemble the ladders
actually the window that would be
logical and if anyone knows markiplier
why did the music stop it's really quiet
all of a sudden if anyone knows
markiplier they know that I am logical
I'm like mr. Spock
tah dah dah dah BAM
just like that I am lai bus don't know
how I assembled those I just spit and
you know it he's yeah I did it
lots of loading screens I will admit
which it makes me afraid because this
one's taking a bit longer of good makes
me afraid whenever it lots of little
experience because I get the feeling
that it's gonna
crash oh Lord
okay so this is the house that was
supposedly barricaded in what my game I
just had to say something my game
crashed okay we're back holy crap
there was no autosave since I started
the game I had to start the game
completely over and go through the
10-minute intro again
whoop-dee-doo okay let's see what was so
amazing in this nothing but oil you
crashed my game for oil I just had to
say something and I'm only like a few
minutes away from being having to end
this so I is just like whatever it's
like whatever I knew I had to do it
anyway but no anger little Peter
don't mess with me oh boy I will
what what what happened did I mess it
what happened stop being startled by
things when I'm not looking
the Haunted carpet so this is good where
are the people that were hiding in here
did they I think they died yeah this guy
got dragged kicking and screaming out of
the closet make me think the baby hiding
in a closet is not a good idea whatever
was here was big footprints you know
what they say about big feet big monster
okay anyway oh this looks nice it's
really nice and by nice I mean
horrifying by nice I mean really
terrible it looks very bad oh thank you
God finally I back to a custom story
that gives me plenty of oil anything in
here that I needed new doors locked and
requires key where have I heard that
before how many keys I'm on I'm fine
yeah that's crew yo doors stuck due to
broken lock my word I need to find a way
to the innkeeper's office lights are
gonna go out of here aren't they
anything gonna be on Oh some weird
sounds going on in the background
well Bienvenue I apologize for not being
able to be here on your first day but at
the moment we only ever have one
customer staying at the inn
her name is Margaret and she should be
fine for a while all you'll need to
serve her is her to do is serve her and
any locals that might stop by my office
is next door to this room and is usually
open so if for some reason you've need
something from there you're free to
enter as you please one last thing if
we'd run out of beer there's a keg in
the cellar
however the cellar door must remain
locked at all times whenever you're down
there I've eyes you to leave quickly and
make sure to lock the door behind you I
don't say this lightly the key is
included with
message best of luck from Arthur yeah
nothing like how you might die is a part
of fear I can't move
look like the Moose man maybe maybe
maybe I don't know okay
so now I am all out of time
unfortunately that's just the way it
rolls with this but don't you worry
because you got non-stop episodes coming
all week long so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos it I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]